what's going on guys chapter 287
of my academia sees the return of all
for one's brother
in an epic battle inside the vestige
world
in this video we'll be going over the
spoilers for this chapter
but be sure to subscribe because on
monday as usual
i'll be doing a full breakdown of the
official release
in those videos we tend to talk about
details that you may have missed and you
know
talk about the dialogue a bit more um so
yeah be sure to check that out
and without further ado let's get into
what we know so far
the chapter picks up with the vestige of
nana shimura coming face to face with
all for one and shiguraki
according to the fan translations she
remarks how unpleasant it is
to have to see all for one even in death
the next part was quite funny in that
all for one begins to roast nana shimura
who is obviously a person that he
personally killed
and he straight up calls her an
incompetent dead woman
right in front of her grandson that's
just uncalled for
at this moment shigaraki has several
flashbacks
the first one being too early in the
battle when gran torinos told him to
stop trampling over nana shimura's
memory
to which shiguraki was like who the hell
is that he also remembers the time as a
kid when his sister showed him the
picture of his hero grandmother and then
the other time when he was about to get
all for one
and she personally tried to stop him he
asked her why she's in the vestige world
to which she just avoids the question
and starts to think about how this is
kotaro's son the whole time this is
going on
we see that afo is using shigaraki as a
vehicle
to materialize himself in this vestige
world
we saw a glimpse of this in the last
chapter with afo literally starting to
emerge from shiguraki's body and that
process
is still continuing here from the scans
it looks like a wave of decay emanates
from shigaraki
and heads straight towards nana shimura
and deku who's currently lying on the
floor
pretty helpless i mentioned in my last
chapter review how
these lines indicated that shiguraki
might destroy the vestige world
and these words begin to ring true as
the decay is now mere
inches away from touching deku i kind of
wonder if this is like the matrix in
that
if you die in the vestige world you die
in real life let me know your thoughts
on this down below
do you think deku would just wake up or
would he just you know actually die here
thankfully in this instance we don't
have to find out because nanashimura
uses her powers in a way we've never
seen before
and by outstretching her hands she's
able to temporarily stop the decay from
reaching them
as this is happening we start to see the
beginning of something we kind of
suspected
in that all for one is kind of betraying
shigaraki
a little bit it's hard to tell i'll get
into this more in a second
but at this point afo is beginning to
materialize more in the vestige world
and the reverse is true for sugaraki
what we see is that as all for one
begins to you know have more of a
presence
shigaraki is actually sinking into all
for one
almost like he's being absorbed or
something all for one's brother then
appears out of the shadows
and stands directly next to nana shimura
can i just say that this guy looks
a lot like shigaraki he's basically what
shiguraki would look like if he had a
good skincare routine
the brother tells afo that they won't be
going with him
and that they've chosen to remain inside
one for all with deku
however as you're about to see i don't
think it's entirely his choice whether
or not that happens
ashigaraki's body continues to be
absorbed all for one is finally able to
pull
his right hand out because if you look
back at the last chapter
all for one's right hand was kind of
merged into shigaraki
but now at this point it's fully formed
afo tells shigeraki that this is true
power
before activating the all for one quirk
for those that don't know
all for one steals other powers by
utilizing the hole
in the hand of its user and in this case
the hole in afo's right hand begins to
suck
in one for all as we see the vestiges of
nana shimura and all for one's brother
begin to be
unnaturally pulled towards it deku is
still on the ground looking up
helplessly
as the decay begins to approach him yet
again and
afo gleefully remarks how passing one
for all to a good for nothing person
like deku
was a big mistake however the first user
of one for all claps back
and says that unlike all for one deku is
a person who does things for the sake of
other people
regardless of how hard it may be deku
watches on
as there seems to be only a little bit
left of shigaraki with most of his body
now being absorbed
by all for one in a moment of
unparalleled heroism
he jumps up from the ground towards all
for one
seemingly with the intention to save
shikaraki
in the last chapter nana shamura
mentioned how deku couldn't move in this
world
but in this panel we see him jumping up
darting forward
with the expression in his eyes that you
know indicates he wants to save shiggy
this was weird to me because midoriya
did say previously how he could never
forgive shigaraki after
you know what happened with gran torino
but yeah in this moment
it's clear that deku's conscience just
couldn't let him stand by
and watch someone get absorbed back in
the real world
a bright white flash explodes in the sky
as the bodies of deku and shiguraki are
sent flying away from each other
i reckon this is sort of like inception
in that even though it may have seemed
like a long
time in the vestige world it was
probably like like one second in the
real world
so i imagine to someone like todoroki
who was watching the fight
it looks like shiguraki just grabbed
deku and then there was an explosion
straight afterwards
i have to point out that we didn't get
clarification on whether shigaraki was
fully absorbed by all for one in this
moment
but my assumption is he was not fully
absorbed because of what happens in the
remainder of this chapter
as both deku and shiguraki fall to the
ground we hear the
thoughts of both all for one and
midoriya to start with deku
he notes how one fool was not taken and
he kind of like internally wishes
for shigaraki just not to move anymore
basically he doesn't want the fight to
continue
as if shigaraki was to regenerate right
now then then everyone would be done for
because
everyone's just super tired deku his
arms are destroyed like he's not go
he's not got any fight left in him so uh
for everyone's best interest
shigaraki cannot move right now
meanwhile off one is in shigaraki's mind
and this bit was really helpful because
it explains why one floor was not taken
in the words of all for one because
shigeraki's operation was stopped at
just 75
completion the all for one quirk was not
fully attached to his body
and therefore there wasn't enough
strength to take one for all
however he then goes on to think that
shiguraki's body shall be completed
and for now they need to retreat and
just you know get shigaraki recharged
let me know down below what you think
all for one's real intentions are right
now
because we saw in the vestige world you
know he's trying to absorb shigaraki
and in my mind that meant that he's
trying to take over shiguraki's body
but from this wording here when he's
telling shigeraki to retreat and get
back to full health and all that
it makes it seem like he's looking out
for shigaraki so it's just a big back
and forth
from chapter to chapter but um like like
the first user of one for all said
afo just does things for himself so i
wouldn't be surprised if his true
intention is to
eventually take over shigaraki's body
the chapter then moves away from this
particular battle
as we get another view of giganto
marquis rampage
dabi continues to be the happiest we've
ever seen him
as he tells skeptic to prepare for hero
society to fall
remember guys it was darby specifically
who chose to bring skeptic along with
the rest of the league of villains
and at this moment you know skeptic does
have his laptop
out which could mean a number of things
as we saw in my villain academia
skeptic uses this laptop to control the
duplicates that he creates
but additionally you know he can also
use it to hack things as well
and someone suggested to me on twitter
that maybe skeptic will hack the news
station
and reveal derby's identity once they
make it to the battlefield
this was an opinion that i personally
agree with because
think about it if dabi was to just claim
responsibility for
gigantomachia's rampage and then he
reveals himself as the son of the number
one hero
it's game over for hero society like how
is the number one hero's son
causing all this destruction so i think
it would be in in the villain's best
interest for them to do this
and yeah that's what i think the plan is
at least for now
the chapter ends with toga and mr
compress having a conversation
although the fan translations on this
bit were a bit dubious so
i'm just gonna wait till uh until the
official translations come out for this
part
all i can say for this video is that
she's talking about ochako and midoriya
but yeah i don't want to get into
specifics because it wasn't entirely
clear
from the translations that i have
personally but like i said
be sure to check out the breakdown on
monday and also on this sunday at 12 p.m
eastern time
i will be doing a live chapter reaction
on twitch so be sure to follow me on
there if you want to see that
but yeah that's everything for today
guys be sure to subscribe and i'll see
you in the next one